[Music]
[Applause]
first up ladies and gentlemen is a
typical animal mascot but with a very
disturbing twist that's right it's the
Easter Bunny kept in a cosmetics lab
that's right
he's been experimented on yeah it's a
horrible tale for this Easter Bunny as
major cosmetics labs have tortured him
and experimenting with him but go ahead
let sieving and slam dunk that would
make everything okay
oh can I just say I love anyone here who
had the gall to boo a tortured Easter
Bunny
all right ladies demand our next mascot
is a necessity on every college campus
it's the ring of birth control pills
there he is
really shouldn't tongue fell for it
birth control pills go for it
[Applause]
is it for later uh okay that's the stuff
our next mascot is a casual dining
institution it's the Ruby Tuesday's
salad bar try and prove each Tuesday
[Applause]
me too
freedom
all right our next mascot was inspired
by the oscar-winning movie the revenant
that's right it's Leonardo DiCaprio
inside a horse which really is leo
everybody trust us on that and go Leo go
[Applause]
couldn't get the ball up our next mascot
looks so depressed our next mascot look
at the other mascots rooting him on
that's that that's just that's just sad
gang
our next mascot honors the work of
playwright Tennessee Williams that's
right it's the Glass Menagerie an actual
Glass Menagerie really shouldn't dunk
really shouldn't dunk and go Glass
Menagerie go
terrible at dunking our final mascot
shines a light on the best feature of a
certain popular singer that's right get
ready for the weekends hair it's the
weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you